back in 2005 a Batman Begins game
launched alongside Christopher Nolan's
film
oddly enough fans never got a sequel to
that even when the Dark Knight came out
though but this doesn't mean that one
wasn't in development thanks to unseen
64 p.m. details on a dark night game
that never saw the light of day the game
would have been called Batman The Dark
Knight and it was being developed by
pandemic studios the same group behind
the original Star Wars Battlefront and
mercenaries playground of destruction
games
unfortunately the open-world Batman game
was rife with problems the video claims
that sticking to a schedule proved
difficult for the developer as it missed
its intended of release alongside the
Dark Knight hitting theaters the
acquisition by Electronic Arts made
things even more complicated the company
set a new release date for the movie
tie-in around December 2008 when the
film would come to home video but it was
clear that the studio wouldn't hit that
release date either and the developers
brisbane australia office were shutdown
the cancelled game left EA with a bill
of a hundred million and a mix final
game was called saboteur which had
players liberating and occupied France
from the Nazis if you want to know more
about this cancelled Batman game check
out unseen 64 video on YouTube but if
it's more gaming news you're after
you're already in the right place